الان الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله حيث
قالت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان وزيره
دفاع بينيكاس قرر عدم تسليم جثمان الشهيد
الاسير ناصر ابو حميد الى عائلته قلقانس
في بان الصادر عن مكتبه ان هو بعد تقدير
للموقف الامني وبتوصيات من الجهات الامنيه
والجيش الابقاء على جثمان ابو حميد جرحنا
الحجز تماشيا مع قرار المجلس الوزري
الامني المصغر والدروره تتعلق بالمفاوضات
على عقد الصفقات تبادل للاسرى والمفقودين
الاسرائيليين وكذا الاسير ناصر ابو حميد
قد توفي في مستشفى
الاسرائيلي نتيجه تدهور حالته الصحيه جراء
اصابته بسرطان الرئه منذ اكثر من عام
وحملت هيئته الاسرى حكومه الاحتلال
المسؤوليه الكامله عن وفاه ابو حميد ما
وصفته سياسه الاهمال الطبيه المتعم ده
التي تتبعها اداره سجون الاحتلال مع
الاسرى
الناطق باسم حركه حماس حازم قاسم قال ان
الاحتلال يضاعف من حجمه وفضاعه جريمه
اغتيال الاسير ابو حميد بقرار منع تسليم
جثمانه لاهله ل وداعه ودفنه واعتبرت
الحركه احتجاز جثمان الشهيد ابو حميد
مخالفه لابسط القوانين والاعراف الدوليه
والانتهاكا لكل معايير حقوق الانسان اما
امين وعمي حركه المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه مصطفى البرغوثي فوصف القرار
الاسرائيلي بالمجرم وحمل البرغوثي المجتمع
الدولي المسؤوليه الصمت على استمرار هذه
الجرائم حسب تعبيره
انا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد مرحبا بك اذا عن قرار بني
جانسي هذا الاخير في التفاصيل ربطه بصفقه
تبادل وفي المقابل خيارات الجانب
الفلسطيني للمطالبه باستبداد ككل
اولا واضح من البيان الصادر عن مكتب وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي بنجانس ان احتجاج
جثامين الشهداء الفلسطينيين سواء كانوا
اسرى او مقاومين اخرين ويصل عددها حتى
الان لدى سلطات الاحتلال الى 118 جثمانا
معتقلا ومحتجزا لدى سلطات الاحتلال من بين
هي احد عشر جثمانه لاسرى فلسطينيين همم
محتجزه ايضا لديهم اخرها كان ناصر ابو
حميد واضح بانها تستخدم للالتزاز لانه قال
بصريح العباره بان هذا يرتبط وتمشيا مع
قرار طاقم الوزاري الامني المصغر الذي
يلزم باحتجاز هذه الجثامين لاستخدامها في
المفاوضات على ابرام صفقات تبادل للاسرى
والمفقودين الاسرائيليين كما جاءت
واسرائيل بذلك ربما تعترف انها ربما
الدوله الوحيده في العالم التي لديها اييي
سجن للجثامين وواضح وفقه ما يراه
الفلسطينيون تحديدا بان سيدنا عندما
تستخدمه ذلك كاجراءات انتقاميه وايضا
لزياده معاناه الاهالي على بشكل خاص علما
بان السلطه الفلسطينيه كانت منذ اللحظه
الاولى قد طالبت مرارا السلطات
الاسرائيليه بان تسلم جثامين الشهداء
وكذلك جثمان الاسير الشهيد ابو حميد الذي
كان اخيرا استخدام الجثامين
لانه اصبح هناك قاعده لدى السلطات
الاسرائيليه بان يتم تبادل الجثامين مع
جثامين اي بمعنى انه لا يمكن تحرير جثامين
لشهداء فلسطينيين مقابل اطلاق همم صلاح
همم
لا
يمكن تسليمها للحصول على اطلاق سراح اسرى
فلسطينيين الاحياء مقابل جثامين لجنود
المصريين محتجزه لدى لدى المقاومه
الفلسطينيه كما هو الحال الان لذائهم
يريدون ان يكون الاستبدال وجثامين مقابل
جثامين في مثل هذه الحاله وبيان همم غانس
كان واضح وان كان هو في يعد ساعاته
الاخيره او ايامه الاخيره كوزيرا للدفاع
في الحكومه المنصرفه الحاليه لكن هذا
الموقف الذي اعلنه صباح هذا اليوم جاء ردا
على الطلبات الفلسطينيه التي تحاول ان
تقنع السيد بضروره تسليم الجثمان وقال في
بيانه غانس بان ذلك جاء بعد عقد جلسه
تقييم امنيه شاركت فيها الجهات الامنيه
الاسرائيليه ويقصد بذلك الاستخبارات على
همم كافه المستويات والجيش وايضا تمشي مع
قرار الطاقه من الوزاري الامني المصغر
وبهذا الرفض انما تضيف اسرائيل من وجهه
نظر على الفلسطينيين جريمه اخرى على جريمه
همم استشهاد
ابو حميد الذي كان يعاني ويصارع المرض
وكان قد طلب الفلسطينيون بضروره اطلاق
سراحه ليكون في حضن عائلته لكن السلطات
الاحتلال رفضت ذلك مرارا علما انه مضى
عليه اكثر من عام تقريبا وهو في السجن
ويصارع مرض السرطان وانتقل في الايام
الاخيره الى المستشفى بعد ان كان قد نقل
مره اخرى في مره سابقه لكن احتجاج تامين
الشهداء الفلسطينيين سواء كانوا اسرى او
مقاومين قتلاتهم سلطات الاحتلال واضح بانه
ياتي ورقه للضغط في حاله تم ابرام صفقات
جديده لتبادل اسرى ومفقوده
شكرا جزيلا لك